first we had one division now we've got
star wars visions
well originally i was gonna do i've just
watched star wars visions hunting fresh
out the kitchen but oh kelly ruined that
intro so that's the best one i've got
anyway you're here now and in this video
we're going to be breaking down every
episode of star wars visions which has
just released on disney plus the new
animated series set in a galaxy far far
away has a lot of callbacks to the
original series movies from across the
decades and several hidden easter eggs
laced throughout it i'm just gonna jump
straight into it but the first episode
is easily my favorite in the entire
series titled the duel it pulls from
several iconic samurai stories and films
from over the years when the ahsoka
episode of the mandalorian dropped many
people compared it to yojimbo by
kurosawa the entry featured several
almost identical shots in it and the
story was very similar too except for
all the space wizards and stuff now the
jewel definitely feels in the same vein
as that and it also pulls on a lot of
iconography from seven samurai in it we
follow a character known as ronin which
in japanese means a samurai without a
master throughout the roughly 13 minute
episode we learn the truth about him and
discover that he's in fact a sith lord
that's adept in the dark side of the
force as we know from the star wars saga
the sith always come in twos with one
being an apprentice whilst the other is
a master however the fact that he
doesn't have one and is straying from
the typical path of a dark force wielder
makes me believe that he killed his
master and decided to go his own way in
which he was somewhat of an anti-hero
now we pick up with him overlooking a
village which is later attacked by
bandit stormtroopers that are the last
remnants of the war he's joined by his
droid ra7 who is donning a japanese
samurai hat and i absolutely love this
design this setup of an adult and
seemingly childlike figure is something
that's known as a lone wolf and cub
motif and it was also mirrored in the
mandalorian upon arriving at the village
he checks in with the sulestin who you
might recognize as being the same
species as near numb we can also catch a
bantha and several other droids and
species including a tuscan raider
sorry sand person a tran doshan which is
the same species as bosque a dog which
is the same species as subulba and a
droid that looks similar to the one in
jabba's dungeon we meet a young child
who has taken over the position of chief
due to his father's illness and he
commands an attack on the bandits which
brings forth their leader who's voiced
by lucy liu the theme from this moment
is clearly paying homage to the ghost in
the shell soundtrack and even her rising
up shares similar iconography to that
first film she carries a lightsaber
umbrella which is playing on the bladed
umbrella weapons that were used at the
time not only as shields but also as a
form of attack she unleashes hell and i
absolutely love how by the energy items
in this episode that everything is black
and white this makes the lightsabers and
blasters really really pop and it gives
the entry such a great style ra7 is
damaged by an explosion and it's plugged
into a gunk droid which are basically
walking batteries in the star wars
universe it's at this point that the
ronin rolls into town and takes on the
bandit leader head to head revealing his
red lightsaber blade he shows he's not a
jedi and we get an awesome bride of
frankenstein-esque moment in which the
leader reveals her hair during this the
tuscan ray
sorry sam person does the infamous
battle cry that was first spotted in a
new hope and the pair duel it out across
the landscape in the background we can
hear similar music to jewel of the fate
and we learn that the chief has
surrendered however now that ra7 is
fully charged it allows them to swoop in
and take down the bandits bringing the
duel to a more level footing after
traveling into a waterfall the ronin
places that lightsaber onto an
ornamental statue to use it as bait and
this allows him to get the killing blow
on the bandit leader the weapons that he
carries are based on the daisho which
literally means little big and this set
of swords is often made up of a long
blade and a smaller one which we see on
display with the ronin he hands over a
kyber crystal to the chief and states
that it wards off evil before heading
off on his own way and then we jump into
episode two now this is called tatum
rhapsody which i feel is one of the
weaker episodes of the lot purely
because of its it's weird out of place
music number now the title may be based
on bohemian rhapsody but the word
rhapsody also means poem we open with
destroyed battle droids and clone
troopers laying on the floor and this
very much signals the end of the clone
wars we pick up with a character known
as jay who is fleeing death in the midst
of order 66. during his escape his
lightsaber breaks but he's saved by a
geezer called giza the hutt who enlists
him in his ranks it's hilarious how oh
he has an emo haircut and a nose ring
and yeah just disney wha wha what the
hell are you doing anyway we learned
that giza left the crime syndicate and
network that the hutt's control so that
he could be a musician that brings joy
to the galaxy with his music together
with his group they tour the universe
playing their songs and this attracts
all types of species including an
idorian and rhodian who clearly aren't
easy to please however it does also
attract the attention of jabba the hutt
who sends boba fett and his palace gods
after the geezer now speaking of geezers
i'm a bloody big one here and if you're
enjoying this video i'd massively
appreciate the thumbs up and also don't
forget to subscribe to the channel for
videos like this each and every day now
giza refuses to go and this leads to
them trying to outrun boba the city they
fly out of seems very similar to
tatooine mixed with bespin and we
learned that the bounty on giza's head
has meant that they have to flee every
show they perform at chased by slave 1
boba ends up capturing giza which is
when jay steps forward he tries to spark
up his lightsaber but due to the damage
it doesn't work and thus we get the idea
laid here that he must bring his power
in through other means barbara takes
giza back to tatooine and the imagery of
him making giza climb into slave one is
very similar to when fetter scored
hanaway in carbonite inspired by the
sound of the first time they played
together jay sets out with the band to
rescue giza from the clutches of jabba
this takes them to tatooine and we see
the twin sunsets which are of course an
iconic part of the skyline from here we
jump to an arena which just so happens
to be the same location as the pod race
track from the phantom menace jabba even
watches over everything from his own
private balcony as he snacks on the
creatures that he did in that film
amongst jabba's forces we can catch his
gamorian gods as well as bib fortuna aka
his right hand man now we learn at this
point that the band made a deal with
jabber so that giza could play one last
gig before the ladder is executed
interestingly fett and bib end up
standing alongside jabba and at the end
of the mandalorian season two we watched
as the former kill the ladder now the
song they play has lyrics in it like the
speed of light for sex and it just
blasts out across tatooine we even see
being watched by the canteen abandonment
size of the cantina and don't feel bad
yeah you got you guys are actually
better in my opinion now some java's
watch it and the song even reaches
obi-wan's house who is probably dead at
this point so yeah good for him that he
doesn't have to hear it i'm just playing
guys i'm just playing yeah disney don't
block me now they play in front of two
torchy towers and these also appeared in
the geonosis coliseum attack in attack
of the clones the power of the music
breaks through and wins the crowd to the
point that jabba even taps his tail and
even though it was supposed to be only
one song they are granted an encore now
episode 3 is called twins and this idea
of twins and doubles is laced throughout
the entry firstly we open with two star
destroyers joined together and then
curtis the two corridors before meeting
our two protagonists these are kari and
ham two dark force sensitive characters
that end up going their separate ways
twins have of course appeared throughout
the star wars saga including luke and
leia and leia's children jason and jaina
i know that doesn't count anymore as
it's not considered canon but they are
very important to bear in mind as these
twins do get some inspiration from them
now both of them trained to be jedi but
jaina ended up staying in the light
whereas jason turned to the dark side
this is somewhat reflected in the pair
that we meet in the episode and again
it's like poetry they rhyme now i kind
of view them as almost what-if versions
of luke and leia and we learn that
they've been manufactured by the sith
for a dark purpose this involves
creating planet destroying technology
that is somewhat similar to the death
star but it requires both to be able to
harness it now they're aboard a ship
called the gemini and this is of course
referencing the twins in both mythology
and astrology gemini has also been used
from time to time to describe two
opposing sites that share some
similarities which the twins in this
episode both do inside the gemini we see
the stormtroopers laid out in an almost
mirror fashion and there are several
shots in the episode which are
completely symmetrical now we learned
that the dark armor they wear powers the
hyper cannon but carrey steals the power
core and we cut to his empty chair which
looks exactly like the emperor's in
return of the jedi upon trying to escape
he's confronted by his sister
stormtroopers and atsts corey pulls off
his helmet to reveal his luke luke and
this point of the episode very much
feels like the anime equivalent of darth
vader versus his son khari even has an
x-wing and an astromech droid called r2o
and am of course just looks very similar
to vader in harama they are of course
relatives too and on the hull of the
gemini they end up going head-to-head
this is probably the most over-the-top
battle i've ever seen in a star wars
property but i did quite enjoy it and it
ends with corey combining all lightsaber
colors to create a weapon powerful
enough to cut through a star destroyer
just not his sister now he also tries to
warn her with a vision of the future
which prophesizes the death that she
would face upon powering up the gemini
he wants the pair to flee however she
refuses to join him and thus corey cuts
the ship with the hyperdrive pushing him
forward in a moment that is clearly
riffing on the light speed one from the
last jedi like i said this episode is
very very over the top and because i
wasn't sure on where i fell on it i
actually watched it three times the
first time i was a bit like yeah this is
too much second i was like yeah this is
slightly better and the third one i was
like yeah you know what i'm really
really enjoying this akari says there is
no try only do and this was of course
what yoda said to luke during the empire
strikes back his sister puts up a fight
but the force of the lightspeed
lightsaber destroys the kyber crystal
inside her armor which means that gemini
can't ever be used kari then splits one
of the destroyers in half and this of
course symbolizes the split between the
two we end with corey on tatooine and
his crashed x-wing and he looks over the
twin sunsets further tying back to the
title of the entry now from here we jump
to the village bride which follows a
jedi on the run from the empire after
the events of order 66. we also learned
that separatists stripped the planet of
its resources and in the end all they
left behind were battle droids these
were reprogrammed by a warlord and his
raider allies and now they control the
entire area the jedi who's listed as f
in the credits is summoned to the
village by an old ally and she observes
the mystical powers that a married
couple possess as well as the traditions
of the villagers themselves kind of felt
like a lot of this episode was sort of
just an anime story with a star wars
name slapped on it and though i wasn't
head over heels with it i did enjoy the
music that was used in the piece we
discovered that the warlord wished to
take the chief but that his daughter who
is due to be married volunteered to take
his place it's very hunger games-esque
and united by the capture of her sister
soku the villagers rise up in order to
stop the warlord and his army of battle
droids he arrives in a ship that looks
like a cross between the millennium
falcon and dash rendar's outrider which
appeared in shadows of the empire the
warlord tries to execute soku but the
blaster bolt has stopped midair by f in
a move that's very similar to kylo doing
the same thing in the force awakens on
the hill we see the elder of the village
sitting with what i believe is an
ambient sniper and f sparks up a yellow
lightsaber which was of course the
colour that rey had too however this is
more of a classic looking sword and she
uses it to kill the warlord before
leaving in her ship which is known as a
clone z95 starfire the next episode in
the series is titled the ninth jedi and
we open a long long time ahead in the
future in a galaxy far far away the jedi
have been near extinction for centuries
and we watch the daughter of a saber
smith named zema who has been mining for
rare kyber crystals that flow around the
planet he wishes to restart the jedi
order and provide them with the weapons
to do so however a number of sith lords
disguised as jedi are hunting for those
that are force sensitive after receiving
a message from the saber smith that
calls them to the aerial temple that
floats above the planet we then join the
sabre smith's daughter who ventures out
to him firsthand we see that he's
created a lightsaber which has an
adjustable blade and this actually pulls
from star wars legends according to
wikipedia in order to do this one needs
a high output deity and power cell that
can change the focus of the lens on the
weapon and transform it so that the
power output and length can be
manipulated however her father has gone
a step beyond this and made it so that
both the length and color depend on the
user's connection to the force his
daughter cara doesn't have a strong
connection yet and this appears in
wheely and also colorless now it's at
this point we get our first inkling that
something is off as jedi hunters arrive
at the location and thus kara has to
deliver the sabers to the temple herself
now his speeder shares a lot of
similarities to darth mauls and she's
chased by the hunters they travel
through a forest and though it's covered
in snow there are some clear nodes to
the one from return of the jedi upon
arriving at the temple the truth is
revealed and bought a few innocent jedi
that also answered the call the sither
of the electro intentions it leads to an
awesome battle and joined by jedi's
named ethan and margrave jiro cara takes
the sith head-on eventually her
lightsaber turns green and they fight to
protect the more grave which we learn is
the main target that the sith have been
hunting after tossing one into a giant
kyber crystal this cracks it and sparks
it up and this actually somewhat carries
the symbolism of a lightsaber which
signals to us that the weapons have
returned to the galaxy they even managed
to bring back one of the sith into the
light and their saber turns purple in
order to reflect this it's actually
possible to make purple by combining the
colours blue and red and it makes for a
nice little nod to the conflict in him
together they head out to find cora's
father who has been taken by the hunters
and she's given the title the ninth jedi
as they travel into the galaxy to
restore order at least she wasn't given
the title the last jedi now next we cut
to tob1 which is of course playing on
the name obi-wan kenobi in it we get
some of the pinocchio story and witcher
droid dreams of becoming a real boy a
sorry jedi now the episode is clearly
horrific on astro boy and the character
designs are very similar we watch as he
lives on his father's moisture farm on a
planet that has dual suns but we find
out that it's not tatooine they wish to
somewhat terraform it and make it
habitable so that people can live there
amongst the rooms in his settlement are
several inscriptions including a wings
and tie fighters the jedi temple x-wings
luke the battle of hoth with 8080s and
atsds y wings star destroyers obi-wan
versus general grievous and lastly a
wampa due to his dreams of being a jedi
his father tells him of a kyber crystal
and he heads out in order to try and
locate this he can't find the crystal
but he's told to find the force and as
we know from star wars droids are unable
to wield it however he does find a t16
sky hopper which you may also know from
being used heavily on tatooine after
sending out a message calling all jedi
the empire discover him and thus his
father has to hide him away similar to
how galen air so did with his daughter
in rogue one the imperials arrive in a
thai reaper and you may recognize these
as being ships in star wars squadrons he
also says the mantra that was made
popular in rogue one aka i am one with
the force and the force is with me now
similar to luke tlb1 finds himself
destroyed but he rebuilds it and
terraforms the planet in order to make
it habitable i love the time spans in
this entry and watching tlb1 slowly
rebuilding everything makes it a really
gripping entry after bringing life to
the planet tlb1 manifests the force and
creators lightsaber i know it's not
really in line with the rules of the
universe but these stories are obviously
inspired by it however i know some fans
will be put off by these little changes
well they're not really little but you
know now i just went with it and toby
one really comes into his own when a
jedi hunter arrives he is knighted by
the spirit of his master and clashes
head to head with a hunter in an almost
black and white battle that calls back
to the first episode this felt way more
classic anime than the majority of the
episodes and joined by his trusted droid
sidekick he charges up before taking
down the hunter in a final strike toby
heads out into the galaxy and yes he's
called toby now and he continues his
father's legacy and we jump to episode 7
which is titled the elder taking place
during the time before the fall of the
jedi this is probably my second favorite
out of the series we join a pacifist
jedi and his padawan who are traveling
to the outer rim in search of a rogue
sith who's living on an outskirt planet
i love the character development in this
especially how the young padawan just
wants action but upon getting it we can
see that he regrets this choice it's not
too late with easter eggs but it's
always good to see a master and
apprentice on these kinds of missions as
they just add so much to the star wars
law we learn that the sith is an elder
that's extremely adept at combat and it
very much plays on the anime trope of
badass grandpa or cool old guy as it's
sometimes called not even kidding that's
what it's called now this is when
there's a badass older man who's almost
as cunning as he would have been in his
prime in the end it's not the jedi that
defeat him but rather time and he very
much represents the old dying to make
way for the young we learn that he broke
away from the sith due to the constant
betrayal that they carried out and this
clearly takes place before the rise of
palpatine who somewhat brought them back
from extinction due to the order he put
in place upon defeating the padawan the
master comes forth and the elder
manifests sith lightning which we saw
pulps dishing out in both revenge of the
sith return of the jedi and rise of
skywalker the master is able to block it
due to his lightsaber and with help from
the padawan he disables the blade and
then shifts before reactivating it to
deal a killing blow i love how much this
pulls from classic samurai films and we
watches the elder crumbles to black rock
and also dust this is an opposite to
when the jedi pass away as some are
absorbed by the force and they simply
vanish upon death now episode 8 is not
the last jedi and we go to lope and ocho
which is another one from the series
that i really enjoyed there's a shot
that feels like it's pulled right from
the opening of solo and we watch his two
characters right across a bridge in
their landspeeder much like han and kira
they end up going their separate ways
and again it's sort of like poetry
because it's very similar now due to the
city structures there's also
similarities to elite a battle angel and
the design of the civilization is
something to behold the episode opens
with an incredible one-shot that takes
us through the locale and we watch as
the imperials have somewhat ravaged the
natural resources that exist there in
order to further their own gains we see
a star destroyer hovering above the city
and this was married in rogue one namely
when we got to jeddah and saw the imps
mining for kyber crystals it's not too
long before we meet lope a peasant
orphan who escaped the empire she gets
caught attempting to steal food by aocho
and her father the ruling family of the
planet however rather than scolding her
they invite lope into their family and
seven years pass seeing what the empire
do to the civilizations that they touch
the father decides to create his own
rebellion on the planet and he launches
an attack on the imperials however his
daughter sees an opportunity by making
an alliance with the galactic empire
where as she sees the imperials
providing growth and prosperity he sees
the imps's occupiers that are getting in
the way of progress due to ravaging the
planet for all its resources in the end
the empire very much win because they
divide the people and it could be a
comment on how governments often aim to
create division among citizens so that
they can gain full control the true
conflict from the entry comes from lope
who must decide whether to side with her
adopted father or her sister she ends up
tumbling over the bridge and upon
falling we can catch a calamari as well
as a group of quarren the calamari is
wearing the blue sweater that we saw one
darning in the mandalorian season two
and you can actually buy these on
clothes websites which i think it's h m
i'm not shouting them out though because
they've not sponsored me now after
learning of a treasured lightsaber
brought to the planet by a jedi her
father passes her the symbol of truth
that it has become when he's taken out
lope takes matters into her own hands
and travels out to take on ocho and the
imperials here she finds out show in
imperial white and much like characters
like kylo she's turned against her dad
in order to hold up the establishment
lopes troy tries to show ocho a photo
that they took on the first day they met
but ocho refuses to look at it and the
pair end up going head-to-head through
the night and into the day lope ends up
defeating ocho and though she flees we
end up with love looking over the photo
once more the three figures reminded me
very much of the three force ghosts at
the end of return of the jedi and that
ends the penultimate episode the final
one is called akakariri akariri akari
akahuri
nevermind and it begins with a crashing
bee wing landing on a mysterious plant
this is by far the most abstract of the
episodes with a strong focus on music
rhythm and also the artwork the
lightsaber fights in it are almost like
a dance and no i felt it was one of the
weaker ones there are some good moments
in it now we follow a jedi who returns
to a planet to help to destroy the
sister of a king who has learned the
ways of the sith it's heavily laced in
japanese storytelling and the idea of a
fallen empire being restored by a lone
traveler who has returned to help this
motif has been adopted into several
western properties such as mad max and
the like but it's very much a staple of
eastern tales along with the princess
the jedi returns to the palace and here
he's tempted by the dark side we learn
that it is his destiny to turn to it and
tricked by the shogun he lashes out at
princess misa and kills her the shogun
says that together they can bring her
back to life and the jedi joins with her
in order to resurrect mise it's very
much a retelling of anakin's story and
how he teamed up with palps in order to
save padme though it has a slightly more
upbeat ending and that misa is saved it
shows that when a jedi loves it can lead
to loss and thus the dark side also did
anyone else hear misa and think of
giorgio binks or was it just mesa anyway
together the jedi and shogun set off
into the stars and that ends the series
now overall there were some ups some
downs but on the whole yeah i think it
was a pretty nice project that had some
great animation in it there were a lot
of standout episodes here but also quite
a few duds that didn't really go
anywhere but there will be an episode
that i think everyone will really enjoy
for me the animatrix is still the height
of what an anime tie-in should be and
though i did enjoy this on the whole
some stopped it from being a complete
recommend across the board that being
said what i liked i really liked and i
hope that lucasfilm make this an annual
thing where they get lots of creators on
board to tell their own unique stories
i'm going to give it a 6 out of 10
overall and that's purely because some
episodes brought it down whilst others
were really really good everyone's gonna
have different opinions on this but i
hope you enjoyed the video and make sure
you leave your thoughts in the comments
below we are running a competition right
now and giving away three copies of zack
snyder's dc trilogy on the 30th of
september and all you have to do to be
on the chance of winning is like the
video make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the series
we picked the comments at random at the
end of the month and the winners of the
last one are on screen right now so
message me on twitter at heavyspoilers
if that's you if you want something else
to watch then make sure you check out
breakdown of the perfect scene in the
mandalorian in which luke skywalker
returns we talked about why this moment
works so well and it's definitely worth
checking out if you want some more star
wars content if not then thank you for
singing through the video i've been paul
i'll see you next time take care peace